aerosol was steamy but Antonio sabato
jr. and Cheryl Burke only scored 25 on
Dancing with the Stars after their first
dance a little too close to the bottom
of the pack I have to say boo to that
that would not have been my score for
you they are here now with me obviously
makes you guys so much for coming in or
pleasure it's always hard to dance first
you know I know I have no one at that
hair I agree well we're just gonna
forget the kasha okay we're going on cuz
you guys have great chemistry and I know
this coming Monday it is the Rumba but
is another very sexy dance so what's the
plan just train every day all day long
footwork and I get hips move in Antonia
yeah and remember a thousand things yeah
about a minute in 23 any sort of like
he's leaving yeah there you go and have
fun and they're fun and relaxed intense
well you know ask the question that
everybody wants to know since the Rumba
is a very sexy sexy dance you're gonna
take a shirt off no we have a plan look
Cheryl I think we can't show that Goods
too early on you know we kind of have to
wait we have to see if people you know
want to see us maybe that week for week
five you can see like this chest area
and this shirt will slowly start coming
off we'll see you got a lot of power
points yeah that's love it if this I
hear about your leafing this coming
season after this one um well this is so
hard always for me to talk about it
because I've been a part of this family
for the last decade and ya know please
do not go I started when I was 20 I'm 30
now and I spent all of my 20s on the
show which completely changed my life
and I've had a blast but you know
contractually I am done this is my last
season I never to have you have back
into second bubble you want to know I
think it's all up in the air still so
we'll see what happens but I really just
want to focus on Antonio and just make
this the best experience for him well
speaking of focusing on Antonio just
before we go I have a little surprise
for you how you do are you ready for
this take a look at this from 1997 and
called-- vetted you of course posing for
legendary photographer Herb Ritts on the
beach I think this be perhaps my
favorite footage ever and Tony so if we
make it to the end he'll wear his Calvin
oh I like that yeah okay you'll see him
in this look again if we make it right
listen to what you actually told as a
kid I always wanted to work with kelan I
just know that he was going to do
something really good artistic so at the
same 100 you got to love that
et vault of ours to have all that old
footage and you have an age to bet I
must say oh you to time thanks so much
for being here appreciate it always good
to see you too
you